it'll be spencer howard on the mound
tonight for the rangers and there's what
he's done and some starts and a little
bit of time out of the bullpen
great job last time out two innings
pitched and no earned runs allowed
versus arizona
howard the young right-hander delivers
and altuve hits a line drive to left
field and a diving attempt by dj peters
keeps it in front of him but altuve is
on with a base hit on the first pitch of
the night
[Applause]
here's the ground ball and this could be
two the second one no
relay throw back to first
julie guriel bats with a runner on third
base
huly hits it down the line and left this
ball towards the wall that will be a
fair ball and go over the wall for a
double altuve will score guriel with an
rbi double makes it one to nothing now
to be up to carlos correa with two outs
howard with the delivery
fair ball down the left field line
hammered by correa that'll be two runs
batted in correa into second base with a
stand up double it's three nothing
astros big two out hit for carlos correa
bottom of the first the astros out to a
quick lead three to nothing for the
right-hander jake odorezzi who takes the
mound today
this will be his 21st start of the
season has a couple of quality starts
under his belt the opponent batting
average at 235 the 2-2 to tavares and
that's lifted out in the left center hit
pretty well but siri back pedals and he
puts it away shoulder high for out
number one now the 2-2
and there's a ball hit on the right side
and into right field
a single for isaiah cainer falefa it
seems like i'm saying this every day
another hit to right for connor falefa
runner stays and the pitch is hit deep
to left field but playable
out there is jose siri to make the play
and that is out number two three nothing
astros connor falefa at second low at
first for the rangers with two outs in
the bottom of the first another one-two
to peters swinging at a miss got him on
a high fastball and the inning is over
rangers get a couple of hits they
stranded both pretty big lead out there
by siri
he's going
that pitch is a line drive base hit to
centers siri never stopped he saw that
well off the bat gets to third easily
how about garrett stubbs a couple of
hits in his last two at bats
now two bay singled on the first pitch
he saw in the first city jose duve has
been putting the ball in play not
striking out a lot and if you shoot a
gap maybe you get garrett stuff to score
there's a line drive base hit
in the score series stubs will be waved
around he's going to score jose altuve a
two rbi double
astros now lead this game five to
nothing
and jordan alvarez stands in he reached
on the fielder's choice and scored his
first time up to oda yordon
that ball's hit high to right field and
deep adolescence garcia will watch it
comrade jordan alvarez number 29 on the
season takes a 2-0 pitch out to right it
is seven-nothing strokes
set ball was in the air forever
106.6 off the bat
they're going to call out the training
staff here as jake voter rizzy threw a
couple of warm-up pitches after covering
first base on that ground ball to julie
guriel did he hit the bag weird he had
to hustle to get to the bag to beat
solac meyer out there the assistant
athletic trainer brent strom looking on
just maybe something at the very end
right when he hit the bag he's going to
leave the game so odor rizzy with a
seven nothing lead will leave the game
after an inning and a third bring up
jose siri theory has made a couple of
plays and left has a single scored a run
now two for five in his young major
league career
and he crushes one to left field this
ball high and deep and there it is the
first major league home run for jose
siri
a two run laser to left
and the astros lead this game nine to
nothing
big swing from jose siri dropping the
head on that one
105.7 off the bat 413 feet that kid is
fired up
1-0 to low the pitch swinging a ground
ball hit to first guriel's got it to
second for one correa puts it in his
back pocket instead of throwing over to
javier who is late to the bag so it ends
up as an rbi ground out and the rangers
are on the board here counts two and two
on low
swing and a miss natan picks up a
strikeout of nathaniel lowe
that's the first out of the inning
astros leading 9-1 over the rangers
bottom of the fifth inning connor falefa
let off the inning with his single
garcia followed with a base hit of his
own they're the two men on
the one-two from maton
how about that pitch phil mata
tots up 90 on the outside edge to strike
out peters who's been struck out three
times tonight here's alex bregman
bregman had a base hit his last time up
as he drives one deep to left field back
on a dj peters near the wall this ball's
gone
alex bragman hits a home run to make it
11-1 bregman's 10th home run of the
season
get to that double digit mark that's the
third home run hit by the astros tonight
there's a line drive base hit into left
field one run will score two runs will
score two rbi single by siri he's driven
in four and the astros lead 13 to
here's alvarez he had a two-run homer in
the second inning
alvarez hits one deep to left center
field and alvarez hits another home run
number 30 on the year a laser beam to
left center field
give yordon
his second home run and a big even 30
and nobody can believe that ball got out
the way it did that is a slider outside
that he absolutely obliterates jose siri
in his first major league start having a
huge night
this ball drilled to left center field
jose siri has done it again
what a night
in his first major league start
four for five
two home runs
five runs batted in
incredible night it's 15 to one
oh yeah
ball game over
what a way to kick off
this four-game series in arlington the
offense went absolutely bonkers and we
got to see jose siri on full display as
he went out there and had a historic
evening